okay so this is about the retina the
right is the back back of the eyes of
the the film in the camera right it's
very very very important structure
because there are many many conditions
that are potentially blinding that are
associated with retina so this talk is
about a computer-assisted analysis and
screening diagnostic of retinal images
okay there are many many types of
retinal images I'm going to concentrate
this talk on one type of retinal image
which is the most common and most
accessible by far okay which is a color
fundus image or the color retinal image
okay there are other things and there
are many other talks that we can and dr.
sad worked with me and Will Rogers is
here he worked with me on this this
summer and he's going to do a quick part
of the presentation and I'll try to give
him the time okay here are some credits
again and here's the abstract so let me
tell you the story basically that's
where the retina is in the back of the
eye and there are a lot of when we talk
about technicalities there are a lot of
contrasts so we're going to talk about
normal and abnormal okay it's still very
important to detect normal images okay I
want to be able to detect normal images
at least to say oh this is normal right
there in terms of the technical
acquisition and our devices that allow
you to get a picture of the retina
without dilating the I putting this
little drops that make your pupil huge
ok so it's an undulating or non
mydriatic exam that's the technical term
so that's an example of a normal
undeleted right I so it's undeleted in a
sense that the device that acquired this
image that did not require you to put
drops and make the pupil huge okay and
that's nice it's nice that we have some
of these devices and and we'll see how
how that
now this is an example of a dilated
right I okay and it's diabetic okay
there are signs of diabetes on this the
lights are a little bright to see
everything but you can see this little
yellow here which is not at all normal
okay and you can see a whole bunch of
little dots and there's kind of a new
blood that you that's not supposed to be
there right and if you look very very
carefully and if we dim the lights can
anybody do blue light in under 20
seconds try try try one more more more
more MORE shut them off if you can no
yeah ok so if so I had a radiology
professor and she used to tell us
hallucinate with me okay so hallucinate
with me and look down here tell me if
you see anything so this is like this
brown yellow little dot okay so these
are actually laser laser spots this I
has been lasered and it has been lasered
because it has diabetes right so anyway
so these are lots of things little
things that I'd like to pick up when I
have so this tells me that yes it has
diabetes yes it's very close to the
center of the vision so this I is in
danger okay it does have your sunblock
bleeding here and so on and well maybe
it's a good sign it has already been
treated maybe two years ago maybe I
don't know when but not yesterday but
but so you have all these things that
you want you may want to be to pick up
okay so more examples of the bad things
that can go on with diabetic eyes and
this is labeled now so this kind of
labeling is sort of what i'd like to get
so i'd like to get the raw image start
with the raw image and then have some
automated system that gives me all of
this all right so it tells me and these
are just technical names for these
things and then i get so that's an
example of macular degeneration okay the
other disease is very very important
very common blinding
is glaucoma and glaucoma usually has to
do with optic disc you know the optic
nerve and this is the front part of the
optic nerve we're at the eye you can see
it in the eye the eye is the only place
where you can see your arteries and
veins it's the only place where you can
see your central nervous system right
actually see the nerve here it is so if
it's whitish like this lots of glaucoma
if it gets completely white it's very
severe glaucoma so it's pretty easy to
detect right I mean you can teach
someone to at least get a feel for this
so we want also the machines to do some
of that do not the good news is that now
we have more and more portable devices
right so look this is a device that will
acquire some pretty good quality images
we took this couple of days ago at the
meet big meeting in Chicago and the
screening is very accessible you can do
you can use the device you can go to the
patient's home you can have a nurse or
technician acquire these images okay and
guess what even the doctors can do it
okay so so that's that's good news
here's an example of this visitor scout
this is as I system the one I was just
showing you and you take the picture and
guess what you have this big abnormal
lesion here which happens to be
toxoplasmosis but doesn't matter what it
is but it is elysian and it's very sent
those to the center but it's not affect
its not in the center so this patient
will still have good vision they may
have a little field field loss here but
you want to know these things and you
want to detect it okay so you can do
screening by human readers and this is
an actual system and so you can bring
this pictures here and then you have a
little input form okay that would tell
you okay do you have micro aneurysms we
have like yellow stuff you have read
stuff do you have this how much right I
left eye and then you can rate the
quality of the image and then you can
submit this to for evaluation okay so
that's not automated but it's it's it's
a human guided or
okay this is a system that I've
developed a long time ago not very long
it's after after Thomas Young I guess
but so this system is based on a
database syst and what it has it's a
collection of the retinal disease not
all so it was called a quarrel atlas of
the retina and it has acquired a new
name that was coined by Jessica ty Bell
Ratan asked and and basically you for
each condition let's say that's a
diabetic condition let's say macular
degeneration let's stay let's say
there's some weird condition that have
names I should target many different
things you don't need to know that but
there are many many of these dozens
maybe hundreds and so and you have a
little sheet the describe them okay and
you put this in a database the database
includes for example the age or the age
range it includes the laterality is it
something that affects one I are both
eyes it includes like preferential for
prevention conditions for same male or
female and so on and then you put this
in an Access database and then you can
interrogate it or query it so you can
put filters so let's say like a 36 year
old woman walks in the clinic and
complains that her left eye sees much
worse than two weeks ago and it was a
gradual onset so you have several
elements that you can put in here with
filters she's not two years old she's
not 80 years old it's a she it's one I
that's affected and transfers if you put
this in is going to filter all of the
other things that don't apply it will
come up with a short hopefully short and
diagnosis or list of possible diagnoses
and it will pull die now this had images
in it but the images were not used to
query okay the images were for
illustration so you pull with the text
okay and then you look and then you ask
yourself is it is this similar to what
I'm seeing in this
sighs okay now the other component is
this area automatic retinal image
analysis is sort of the other side the
other pole of this equation so what you
want to do is to look at an image and
extract from it all of these features
that i was talking to you about like
when we looked at the diabetic patients
like the bleeding the yellow spots how
close they are to the center why should
you in the glaucoma optic disc and and
so on and so forth so the whole history
here of this field it's a fairly young
field and I'm not going to do too much
of this because I want to give will some
time but the uses are obvious or maybe
not so obvious one of them is screening
well if someone comes in and they are I
don't know 8,000 miles from my clinic
and I don't have a specialist in retina
to you know really tell them what's
going on and what I want to at least
know let's say they're diabetic I want
to at least know are they in trouble or
not right and maybe they're not in
trouble at all maybe with a fine maybe
you can see them in five years right so
you have to do this screening you don't
need a very exact diagnosis or very
exact 30 onto the screen now of course
the emetic retinopathy is a huge huge
huge huge issue now all over the world
okay place in the world what people used
to starve to death have exactly opposite
problem now everybody is getting huge
and eating eight times more than the
shed and acquiring diabetes sometimes in
the first decade right of life so that's
that's going to be huge so you want a
computer-assisted I know sis and risk
stratification very important you want
to do longitudinal studies or you want
to even follow your patients today in
one year in five years ago and see how
things are and then compare and you may
want to be looking at some kind of image
guided surgery for some applications
okay so telehealth is very important and
are examples of that optic this
detection method just as an example this
is an example is from a paper very
recent paper it shows all of the methods
that have been used and with the degree
of success I'm listing some of the
techniques here that have been used by
different everybody uses a slightly
different method and they have
reasonably resource access and so on my
main point from this slide is that first
of all there are some standardized data
sets on which you can use try your own
algorithm if you come up with something
and the other one is that most of this
functionality that everybody's doing
different implementation whatever
language I using all of this is really
available in mathematical right so you
can house this whole structure in in in
in a mathematical framework and like
shadow was saying okay we have all of
this so audio and imaging okay and it's
very nice there's all these new features
you know it's like 11 but ok one huge
thing is that they are all sitting in
mathematic and you can use this whole
functionality so we can take this audio
file and save my audio file plus 2 / 7
right or whatever other okay so here is
an example of mathematica image analysis
what we're trying to do here is is that
where the arteries and the veins are and
this was a very simple function so we'll
is going to come and show you a couple
of things he has worked on and I'm going
to give him five minutes and then I'll
conclude in five minutes and would be
the most amazing talk of the whole
conference because we'd be on time so
we'll can put this in your pockets this
or that whichever
[Music]
so we'll work with me the summer and
continues to work on this is in high
school here in town alright so here we
have so what we're trying to do is that
we're trying to find the optic disks
inside the picture of the retina and to
one of the methods I develop was a kind
of sliding window so you kind of look at
all the possible places the opposite
this could be in the eye and then try
and figure out which one of those has
the optic disc one way we can do that is
if we look at the picture the optic disc
is one of the brightest places in the
eye so we can narrow it down pretty
quickly and then try and identify which
of the brightest places is the optic
disc so that's one way to find optic
disks and then we also you did do the
vein detection is another method for
showing which is this which we saw
earlier so we're highlighting the veins
in the eye which can be important to
know like what the structure of the vein
is for identifying certain diseases that
might be affecting your eye and to that
we use gradient filter which is one of
the functions available in Mathematica
which MIT which is almost like a
derivative kind of in mathematics where
it will tell you what the change is in
the brightness so you take one pixel and
compare it to the brightness of the area
around it and see what the change is and
it creates a new image with each pixel
being the change of the brightness in
the area from the area around it so if
we clean this up and overlay the picture
we can get
an outline of the veins of the eye all
right and it's a mere good wrap it up or
I alright alright then stay here because
they have question for you I just
borrowed this thank you you can sit and
be available ok so I'll just wrap wrap
up this by saying that what we are in
the process of doing is to integrate
this area of automated diagnosis like
pulling from the images to the database
system that we had already developed and
of course it needs further development
to as we as we make this this fusion or
is this interface and also as we have
more imaging modalities that become
available to us one example I told you
that the wretched ask was developed
little bit before two thousand and was
presented in two thousand now after this
is a technique called optical coherence
tomography which is a very sophisticated
technique that is a lot about the retina
and a lot about diabetic retinal ott
about macular degeneration saw so
definitely if you want to integrate this
of course it becomes more expensive your
this whole more complex and whatnot so
you want to balance things in the side
what kind of system on to develop but
again just in the integration process so
in conclusion right a task is a text /
numeric based system area generates text
n numbers from images so you can take
the image generate the text and the
descriptions and some numbers and then
you can feed this interest ask so
retinas then screens classifies
diagnosis you have many semi
quantitative criteria in ophthalmology
so when we classify things we say
especially you two studies so you say
well is the
little yellow dot closer than 500 micron
or further than 500 micron from the
center of the retina for example right
so there are things like so this is kind
of a natural place to do this kind of
analysis of course a lot like Stephen
was saying yesterday he's very
interested interested in computational
x.x being anything from anthropology to
zoology right so there are journals of
computational biology for example right
and so and so forth but so that some
fields that haven't yet added the label
computational okay so here's a this is a
natural place to add the label
computational because we do things
quantitatively already an example is the
clinically significant diabetic rat
retinal Deema that's potentially
blinding and it also that classification
will give you useful enter in
information such as the need for
treatment okay so it's a very important
to get a good screening and diagnostic
tool so I'm going to stop here to give
an opportunity for people to ask
questions you can ask me you can ask
well and then we'll also not interfere
with the next talk in this in this room
thank you